welcome back to cbs saturday morning
some actors make a big splash in
hollywood with starring roles in
blockbuster films others end up playing
the long game showing up in smaller
parts and careers that can endure for
decades and of those few can match the
record of a man who was honored this
week marci gonzalez has his story
can we get an order of dumplings but
with three instead of four no
substitutions
this isn't a substitution it's a
reduction okay no reductions
you've seen him in some of the most
popular tv shows of all time from the
big bang theory to seinfeld how much
longer is it going to be
about five ten minutes
and he was making his mark in movies
long before that
you wait you wait in classics like
chinatown
i could go on for hours but i'd probably
start to bore you comedies like airplane
i really couldn't blame elaine she
wanted a career
and even animated fair as a voice in
kung fu panda paul forget everything
else
your destiny still awaits we are doodle
folk in his nearly 70 years in show
business james hong has appeared in
nearly 700 movies and now my beloved
disciples and tv shows
maybe we could have a little workout of
our own no no boom boom before big fight
making him one of the most
prolific actors you may have never heard
of until now
a lot of people know your face
but maybe not your name
what is that like
i don't like it
i wish they could you know look at my
face and then say james hong you know
some of them do at 93 years old that
wish is now coming true along with a
much bigger one
hong was honored this week with a star
on the hollywood walk of fame the oldest
performer ever to receive one how
surreal is it to look down and see your
name there i can't get over it really to
see it there it's
really something it means a lot born in
minnesota to chinese immigrant parents
he moved to california in the early
1950s he worked as an engineer until
trying his hand at acting quickly
landing the roles that launched his
career
i think this first movie was with clark
gable and soldier of fortune
from that i did blood alley with john
wayne
but in those days it was almost all uh
cliche roles gimmick roles but we never
got to play the leading roles when i
first started so that was a big handicap
two specials oh no two hong kong but i
heard you say two specials
set out to change that in 1965 he
co-created the east west players a
theater group still active today with a
mission to expand roles for asian
americans
and then of course i i tried to convince
the producers and directors
in the guild to use the asian americans
you know it's a very slow process as you
can see it took 70 years what can i say
after decades of paving the way for
other asian american actors a famous
friend decided it was time to carve out
a place in hollywood history for him
hawaii 5-0 star daniel day kim nominated
hong for the walk of fame star and even
started a fundraiser to pay for it no
one will let blaze the trail the way
that james hong has kim was at the
unveiling ceremony along with jamie lee
curtis
mrs wang are you with us who stars with
hong in the newly released sci-fi comedy
everything everywhere all at once
because even at 93 hong hoo some call
the hardest working man in show business
is still full of energy and the drive
that's guided each step of his still
thriving career so i don't really want
to give up acting i don't want to retire
you know i'm due for a vacation but
i i think acting is my vacation besides
you are very successful for cbs saturday
morning i'm marci gonzalez in hollywood
man nice when your job can be your
vacation by the way there are more than
2 700 stars on the hollywood walk of
fame only 19 of them represent asian
americans which includes james hong now
yeah good for him
nearly
700 yeah movies and tv shows that is
just
clark gable to mike meyer
i know
how about that amazing